en un comunicado oficial El Vaticano
confirmó este jueves que el Papa
Francisco pasó una buena noche en el
hospital Romano en donde permanece
hospitalizado desde ayer a causa de una
infección pulmonar diagnosticada después
de una serie de controles el cuadro
clínico Mejora progresivamente y
continúan los tratamientos previstos
dice el comunicado Francisco está siendo
atendido por un grupo formado por
cardiólogos neumólogos y expertos en
medicina interna que le han solicitado
reposo absoluto razón por la cual Por el
momento no se sabe Por cuánto tiempo
deberá permanecer hospitalizado ni De
qué manera esto afectará a los eventos
previstos durante la semana santa
Francisco tenía previsto celebrar la
misa del domingo de Ramos al abierto en
la plaza de San Pedro para dar inicio el
próximo domingo a las celebraciones de
semana santa que son el momento más
importante del calendario católico Pero
dadas las circunstancias en el Vaticano
circula la hipótesis que esta
celebraciones no sean presididas por el
sumo pontífice este año quien a sus 86
años de edad parece más que nunca
frágilizado por estos problemas de salud